Quaternions represent the orientation of an object, how it's rotated. They can
do the same thing as axis angle rotations. They rotate a model around a given
axis by an angle. They get a lot of use in animation because you can easily
interpolate between one orientation and another. Think of two vectors poking
through a sphere at the origin. If you want to change your orientation and go
from one vector to the other, there are a number of ways you can do it. Say you
want to do this over four frames. You can't normally do this well with Euler
angles. The change in direction is likely to need more than one Euler angle
changed at a time. Changing two Euler angles at once can give you problems with
Gimbal lock, as one angle is applied before the other. Euler angles are
terrible for interpolation around an arbitrary axis, especially when the change
is large. Using an axis angle scheme, you would go a quarter of the angle and
form the matrix. Every frame would need to form a new matrix, which can get
pricey. Creating each takes a number of trigonometric function calls.
Quaternions are a third solution. You can set quaternions to perform the same
interpolation in a clean way and in a form as compact as Axis-angle - just four
values. No trigonometry calls are needed. Quaternions themselves are fairly
non-intuitive as to what their four numbers mean in physical terms when
compared to Axis-angle. However, just like you rarely look at a single number
in, say, a rotation matrix, the meaning of the Quaternion's individual values
doesn't really matter when you're using them. When you interpolate around an
axis, it's called a SLERP, short for spherical linear interpolation. All this
means is that you're moving from one point on the sphere to another in a direct
and linear fashion. 3JS and many other packages support quaternions because of
the simplicity. In 3JS, if you wanted to use angle axis rotations, you'd also
have to maintain your own translation and scale matrices for the object being
rotated. Because quaternions are fully supported as a separate interpolation
system. You can enable these in 3JS, while still using the position and scale
parameters. Quaternions make it easy to specify and interpolate between various
orientations. Similar to rotation matrices, but with less values involved, you
can also multiply quaternions together. Doing so produces a new quaternion that
is a result of this series of rotations. Quaternions are often used for
animation paths or flying controls. In fact, 3GS uses them for just that class,
FlyControls.js. That said, you do have to be careful in using quaternions with
cameras, in that the up vector will not be maintained throughout the SLERP, and
you'll need to reorient. Try the demo that follows. It moves the bird's hat
back and forth on its head in a jaunty way. You can choose to interpolate using
Euler angles or quaternions. With Euler angles on, try setting the angles to
their maximums. If you look from above, you'll see that the path is not
straight around the head but rather takes an s-shaped curve.